[Music]
he just jumped dance it's pitch black
out there you don't know if he has a
phone money anything how worried are you
and how scared are you for just his
well-being
well as I told him I what do you Liam
Neeson you're gonna go to the embassy I
mean he said it well I grabbed my wallet
like right that's gonna you don't have a
phone you don't have your passport where
are you going
how long did it take to fight I really
don't know because I mean I would say
you know five minutes went by or so and
then I we all came together back at this
crossroads and there's the producers and
I mean everybody was there and we called
back to Los Angeles so this much time it
passed and we woke up other executive
producers and executives said this is
what's happening what do we do and they
said at some point you're gonna have to
call the authorities so I was we said
look let's give it five more minutes and
we're gonna call the cops and bring in
the cavalry because we have to find this
human being because we're responsible
for him and so luckily as we were about
to do that
someone's walkie-talkie clicks and I
hear we got him or we found him and then
that's where we'll pick up with a
finality that you will see us chase him
down and did you find him because he
came back on his own ish he didn't come
back on his own but we found him because
he this sounds terrible but he exposed
himself he gave himself up in a way that
we found him
not a good Liam yes he's not no he's not
a good Liam Neeson he's not Rambo he he
is gone does anyone have any idea where
he is and he just kind of broke and
snapped and he was done and then what
you'll see after this is kind of the raw
real emotions and it's not pretty it's
not pretty on my part it's not pretty on
the producers part or Colton's and I
think you're gonna see it warts and all
and it is really emotional and on all of
our parts a lot of tears were shed and a
lot of things were said that may not be
suitable for ABC but we all kind of
aired our grievances and let it all out
grievances with each other with Cole all
of it Colton was upset and so you know I
think part of the blame he felt was on
our shoulders and part of it was his own
and part of it was just frustration
because of you know his pride and
embarrassment of thought he found the
love his life and it turned out he
didn't and so they just yeah there was
just you know when you run hot things
are said did you okay I will say we got
him what you'll have to see there was we
all got emotional
[Music]